the St Louis Cardinals you play for yeah
so I got drafted
rosarina rips it to left
warning track wall it's gone they found
out that I was a professional baseball
player they thought that I had money uh
so they were trying to extort me but the
Latino Community is just on the rise
with Islam Islam is a religion that is
growing by the day research from the Pew
Research Center shows that Latino
representation among Muslims in America
is on the rise in 2011 Latinos made up
six percent of the Muslim population in
2017 that number was up to eight percent
and there's a new study underway right
now which gives us an update on growth
in the last six years I got that guy
beat up
you got the Muslim beat up no if it was
because I got Jesus Christ tatted on my
on my on my left arm or that I I used
the Bible and I always had a Bible in my
back pocket I know I had an addiction to
women it got the alcohol uh started to
get to me it got me to pick up the Quran
yeah once I picked up the Quran it was
game over and I met the Muslim there
again the guy that I got beat up
[Applause]
let me introduce
and his final message
[Music]
foreign
listen if you want an opportunity to
support dawah to get this this is the
project for you to do that I'm saying to
you very clearly you know whether it's a
dollar or whether it's a million dollars
this is the project that you need to
support so we can have a template you
know for dawa and a community and we
need to ask Allah to duplicate this here
10 times All Over America
center in Tampa Florida
how are you doing my brother good good
former professional baseball player for
the MLB
will
pull
it's good to have you on the D show it's
good to be here
and you were also the Christian I didn't
know this many people are not going to
know that you you were the league
actually had a Christian representative
and you were the head of that also is
that correct yes yes I was the what they
called the uh the representative of
baseball Chapel in the minor leagues so
essentially what happens is we have
church for Christians uh for the
Christian baseball players and I would
get with the chaplain on Wednesdays we'd
go over uh the material that we were
going to speak about on the Sunday on
Sundays I made sure that the players who
were Christian would show up now before
we even get into that I mean you I just
can imagine you reminded me of another
person who's from the Dominican Republic
the famous baseball player he's from
Chicago yeah Sammy Sosa Sammy Sosa yes I
mean Sosa slam and Sammy I mean he's
slamming Sammy he's the one he's a
legend in the uh oh yeah he's a he's a
legend not only in baseball but in the
Dominican Republic have you met him uh I
want to say that I did when I was a kid
I'm not too sure though I met so many
baseball players because I come from
baseball family I played baseball my
father had grown up as a kid and then I
have a cousin who just retired with 703
home runs and he was a huge what
position did you play so I played
Outfield Outfield yes that's how I was
drafted um I came up playing all
positions but whenever I got drafted I
got drafted as an outfielder we were
talking a little bit and you were
telling me that now because you you
think okay you're living a dream now you
made it yeah right you made it to this
professional your professional athlete
professional baseball player then A
Whole New World opens up oh yeah and
that opened up to you huh and you said
you got to meet you said this is how I
knew the devil was true yeah no yeah no
definitely you know I was sheltered as a
kid right and my parents were Catholics
you know we went to Catholic church on
Sunday I ended up going to a Catholic
School
um while I was going to high school and
I hadn't really been out into the world
I hadn't really seen too much other than
what I saw on TV and what I saw from my
family which were always you know
usually good things and when I became a
professional baseball player I started
looking around you know I was now
introduced into the world
uh down in West Palm Beach and it was
the night scene the the nightclubs and
the cars the money you know we kind of
had to keep up right because you have to
keep up that
that look that image
and it put a lot of pressure on me
um got a lot of peer pressure from
outside people and I wasn't ready for
that it was the St Louis Cardinals you
played for yeah so I got drafted by the
St Louis Cardinals and what happens in
baseball is once you get drafted then
they move you into the minor leagues and
then you you work your way up to the big
leagues so I essentially was drafted and
then I had to work my way up so I didn't
get too far up
um but I but I did get to be around you
know the MLB Superstars and you know the
people who had already made it so even
before you got to that level now what
was it that started to open up I mean
was it just now you're coming up and
money's coming in you know you're
talking about you have your your crew
now yeah and what's happening so I got a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars to
sign and let me say that back in 2005 it
was a lot more money than it is now I
had never seen this type of money ever
uh definitely blinded me a little bit
and I I something I wasn't prepared for
I didn't have the financial education
um but then at the same time what
happened is that everybody became my
friend right my friend and I ended up
having an Entourage and I honestly
didn't know how to choose the friends
um you know as a Christian you always
want to see the good in people right and
I gotta say I didn't have the
instruction
to know how to choose individuals
but at the time I just wanted protection
and I wanted to have a crew around me
everybody else had a crew around them
and I guess I didn't choose the right
people but
yeah money girls are women
um just everything just came out of
nowhere but these seem like too opposite
world because still you're a Christian
you're somebody who's supposed to be
representing Christ you're supposed to
be christ-like you're supposed to be
away from chasing your desires still as
a Christian aren't you yes definitely
definitely I I feel that in Christianity
uh we lack instruction as Christians
right I know as a Muslim now I know how
to choose my friends I know you know
what to do even when I enter a bathroom
when I go into a house I say Bismillah
you know
um we're instructed to be around certain
type of people the people that are
making God happy
and I'm not going to tell you that
there's no instruction in Christianity
but but it's not the same as Islam
because what I see in Christianity uh
especially from the people that I grew
up around was the more money that you
had
the higher in rank you were versus in
Islam the closer you are to God the
better Muslim you are the higher rank
right so it seemed like
when I started making more money than my
family
um my parents now I had the authority
but where does my authority come from
and that's where I was lost I didn't
know exactly what I was supposed to do
and how are the other Christians in the
league and how do they pick you now to
be the head you're the head
representative for the Christians yeah
in the MLB yeah Minor League Baseball so
the way they chose me I don't know if it
was because I got Jesus Christ tatted on
my on my on my left arm or that I I used
the Bible and I always had a Bible in my
back pocket you always had a Bible in
your back pocket I always had a Bible no
joke and one thing that I noticed was is
that
no matter how deep my Christianity was
my relationship with Jesus Christ or God
I honestly can't tell you I was very
confused
no matter how that was
that didn't affect anyone on the outside
people still just looked at me like a
regular person I wasn't praying or
anything like that where people would
see now as a Muslim way I gotta go pray
right do her is coming up as a Christian
you really don't have that so the
outside forces you know they could get
you very easily because we that's the
instruction that I'm talking about we
really don't have the instruction on how
to live the day-to-day life you know
versus you know being a Muslim we don't
have to pray five times a day
so the other Christians I want to say
they fell into the same temptations that
I fell into you know it was my Christian
brothers that I would go to the club
with you know I would be talking to
girls with them you know we mix and and
you know go out to the mall and spend
money and Flash
so
I I don't really even know how to answer
that nowadays you know because now being
a Muslim I I it's clear for me you know
what I'm supposed to do what I'm not
supposed to do I mean nobody could say
that you weren't someone you were
heavily invested you got Jesus tattoo oh
yeah Bible in your backpack okay you
knew your Christianity obviously yeah no
I I look I love Revival I love Jesus I
love Jesus and and just no we'll get
into this deeper but you still love
Jesus yeah oh no I love Jesus even more
now yeah okay as a Muslim as a Muslim I
love Jesus more because now I understand
his message uh via the Quran I I
understood his message like never before
and I understood what God wanted out of
Jesus message so now I feel like I'm
doing what Jesus asked me to do versus
what others told me to do so no one can
say look he didn't know his Christianity
he wasn't a real Christian oh no no no
no no no everyone who knew me was they
knew that I was about Christ they knew
that I was a devout Christian
they knew that not only did I go to
church but I would try to bring people
to the church and that's the reason why
I feel like they picked me as a
representative baseball Chapel was
because I invited everyone and not only
that I spoke English and Spanish there's
a lot of Spanish speakers in these
professional baseball teams so I was
able to communicate with with both the
English and the Spanish players I was
just watching a report not too long ago
and it was showing that the Latino
Community is just on the rise with Islam
there are more and more and more Latinos
except in Islam yes yes so you know one
thing that I learned you know after
becoming a Muslim was Our Roots a lot of
our roots are in Islam because you know
in Spain before whatever happened that
the Catholic Church took over it was a
Muslim Nation right so essentially what
happened especially in my country was
in Spain the the queen did not want
Muslims or Jews in her in her country
anymore so they ended up coming to the
Americas uh Christopher Columbus
discovered Santo Domingo Dominican
Republic though the country I was born
in and he spread Catholicism but the
people that were there with him that he
brought over were Jews and Muslims
so I want to say that we have it in us
and we just don't know this is forgotten
knowledge you know and it's almost
become Forbidden Knowledge because you
know I've noticed that if I speak about
Islam I get
backlash really quick you know and
that's something that we can get into if
you want to yeah what have you come to a
point where you decided to look further
into Islam and and if and just really
thinking about purpose of life you know
you're a Christian tattoo uh Jesus you
got the Bible in your back pocket and
you're partying so you're Between Two
Worlds you're confused now here comes
Islam and how does Islam come into the
picture at all okay so you know
playing baseball I got around the wrong
people and
I started to lose a lot of money so I
wanted to make fast money and these
individuals so happen you know how to
make that type of money so you know just
being around them being influenced by
them I ended up getting wrapped up in
something now
they never really wanted to tell me what
it was about it was a situation where
you know I went to jail and
it's almost like this Andrew Tate
situation he goes to jail he's in there
they're investigating but there's no
charges same thing with you same thing
with me although here in America Works a
little bit different but I was in jail I
was in there for months right
but they didn't tell me exactly what I
did or anything and two things happened
while I was in jail all right and this
is in the span of 10 months while I was
in detention
I learned about Islam in the jail in the
jail I learned about Islam this isn't a
County Jail there's a County Jail you
didn't go to Penitentiary no no no no
this is a Detention Center yeah and this
is a place so they can go and
investigate and see what they can bring
to a tribe yeah so
my my my network of of guys led me there
right bad friends bad friends
because you know I I didn't have I
didn't have the guidance to know exactly
who to have around me I was very blind
as a Christian I thought everyone was a
good person
so I ended up in jail uh for something I
did not do you got exonerated I got I
got exonerated from the heinous charges
they were uh charging me with
but during that time that's when I met
uh Muslims who were practicing
and they told me about Islam now I
didn't want to buy it right I was still
holding on to Jesus I was still holding
on to the word
but one thing happened and it was I got
into a debate with a Muslim in jail and
he beat me
he got me how did he get you well he
proved to me that Jesus wasn't God
and the way that he did that was using
common sense and it was actually things
that I had always questioned as a
Christian you already were questioning
me I was already questioning this was
just solidified now the Muslim comes and
he gets you to appoint your stuff to
like okay he got me to pick up the Quran
yeah once I picked up the Quran it was
game over I knew it was the truth right
but when I had this debate he asked me
okay will you believe Jesus Is God
correct I said yeah I believe Jesus Is
God but he said but wasn't Jesus praying
he said yeah well he was who was he
praying to so he was playing praying to
God he was like
you just said Jesus was God so why was
he praying to God
so then I went into circles into circles
and then I'm thinking in my mind I I
said
this isn't right
so something crazy ended up happening at
this time I had a crew in jail
I got that guy beat up
you got the Muslim beat up because I got
the muscles to you that Jesus was he
proved to me that yeah and I was I had
this type of jealousy or something
inside wow I got him beat up and uh they
took him away
I stayed in there
and then I started to learn about the
law
I was very frightened because I didn't
know why I was in jail
I didn't have any lawyers at this point
I had already lost all my money
so I would go to the law library every
single day
so when I'm learning the law I learn
about contradictions
if you tell the police officer something
and then you go to court and you say
something different
you're basically lying you're
contradicting yourself
well
I picked up the Old Testament and then I
read the New Testament of the Bible and
I started seeing all the contradictions
and I was like this isn't right
maybe this guy
had truth to him
and then another amazing thing happened
which was
I now have
good understanding of the law I have a
knack for it
so now I'm helping guys out around me
with their cases
they weren't very educated where I was
at I was I had my education and then I
was learning the law at the same time so
I would help these guys
I noticed that the guys that helped me
that wanted me to help them were the
Muslim guys
the other guys the Christians they all
were saying oh he's a jailhouse niche he
doesn't know what he's talking about
don't trust him and these are the guys
that I was going to you know the Sunday
church with in jail
the Muslim guys
you know they they would say I'm gonna
go prey on him uh I got instruction from
a law that that you're a good person
you're a trustworthy person I said who
is this a law and why do you why do you
guys believe but I noticed that they
they were Believers right they were
believing in me and I was honestly
telling the truth I you know I I try to
tell the truth to all those guys in
there
um and then I helped this one guy
I helped him and he would always pray
always come back to me always pray
always come back to me I helped him get
out
and it felt really good inside
and he said welcome to the gym I helped
him get out of the jail and he said well
I I appreciate everything that you're
doing but I want you to have this he
gave me a Quran
so then I was reading the Quran after
that
I started to see the truth in the Quran
everything made sense it all started to
come together it all started to come
together wow it wasn't telling me not to
believe in Jesus it wasn't telling me
not to believe in the Bible it was just
telling me
how to believe in Jesus how to believe
in the Bible
it started connecting all the dots that
I needed to know now I understood
Jesus's role now I understood the roles
of all the prophets now I understood the
world of God
now I understood what God wanted from us
and how to see these people
who were going to take me astray I
started to see that
so
something happened after that
I almost got killed
individual came in
um a guy with a bunch of guys uh they
found out that I was a professional
baseball player they thought that I had
money uh so they were trying to extort
me uh they beat me up really bad
and then they ended up taking me to a
segregated uh place in the in the county
jail
and I met the Muslim there again the guy
that I got beat up the one that told you
that Jesus was praying how could Jesus
be God yeah like that you get him beat
up and now you run into him again I run
into him again if you got beat up after
I got beat up how things uh came around
huh things came around
so I told him look I had the I have the
Quran now I'm sorry brother for
everything that I did and he said well
whenever you're ready to take shahada
you can take your shahada with me I
ended up taking my shahada with him and
he and he taught me how to uh pray in
Arabic
and uh as soon as that happened it was
like Allah was putting all the pieces
together and I ended up getting out
so I know that that was my mission from
Allah to go into the county jail to get
you to go through this experience so you
can be gifted and everything else
in jail came out exonerated free of all
the charges yes but you had to go
through that I had to go through that
where you're at today here yes
yes so imagine how I felt whenever I saw
that brother again you know I hugged
them
I told him I was sorry and he acted like
nothing had ever happened
you know and and I just remember you
know um when I was a Christian
I had never felt that type of
Brotherhood I had never felt
someone
truly forgive me you know
it was always oh I got something against
you or I'm gonna use it as soon as I can
you know and Allah speaks about all of
these things in the Quran you know he
talks about the Believers and the
Hypocrites you know he talks about what
we should look out for all the signs are
in there so in the end people ask me
well how you became how did you become a
Muslim okay with the Quran
I challenge everyone
to read the Quran who hasn't read it
the truth is in there
I I don't know how to explain it to
anyone else the truth is in there
especially if you're a Christian and you
have those doubts because things don't
really make sense to you which you know
I run into a lot of guys that feel the
same way I tell them pick up the Quran
you know it's not something I want to
force it's not just pick it up pick it
up read it read it tell me this what
goes through the mind of someone who's
Christian help us understand this and
you have this concept of original sin
Jesus dying for your sins we have the
kinds of taqwa that God Almighty is all
seeing all hearing he knows everything
got the angel on the right writing the
Good Deeds one in the bad Deeds so
you're always conscious of your actions
and if you make a mistake you repent you
go straight to the creator of Heaven
Center nobody's dying for your sins
there's no JC Gold Card put it on him
he's taking it away from no so this
taqwa the more you have God
Consciousness fear of God love of God
this helps to keep you in check but over
here let's say what's the concept if
you're you're in the nightclubs like you
were at that time are you thinking as a
guilt kicking in and you're just like
what do you do then you go some Hail
Mary's you're thinking like okay Jesus
Paid for for my sins I'll be okay what
goes through your mind is what was going
through your mind we get a better
understanding it's a battle it's a
battle
um it's not consistent you know let's
say I went to the nightclub right and I
had to go to church the very next
morning you know I would just think to
myself well Jesus died for my
yeah I'm getting away with it you know
and I can tell you now being a Muslim
for so many years I look back at myself
and I just laugh you know like
how could I ever believe that
you know because as a Christian we read
that God is just
so how is God just if you're a bad
person or you're doing all these bad
things and just because you believe in
someone you're going to heaven
so so
what am I supposed to do if I do
something really bad
and I feel really guilty about it what
am I supposed to do
just believe that someone died for me
and that's where I feel like a lot of
Christians fall off because we're very
confused
you know you asked me to explain these
things to you but I really can because
there's no one there's really no
explanation
we're we're told believe that Jesus died
for your sins and you're going to heaven
but we're not told
pray a certain times a day do this do
that there's no instruction that goes
along with the structure like you were
saying there's no structure so it's very
very easy to say someone gives you the
structure oh yeah when everything is
laid out yes from business to family to
if you want to divorce marry even going
to the bathroom yes and then like you
know so many realize how could a man
living in a desert come up with all of
these things and we're not talking about
the prophecies the sign the scientific
facts Miracles things that are just it's
just it's mind-blowing it's mind-blowing
that a human being can come up with it
it's not just Blind Faith so when I read
the Quran
the first thing that I asked the Muslims
around was when was this book written
there's no way it was written so long
ago they said well that book was written
1400 years ago
and I said yeah but there's got to be
some type of revisions or something
because how does the prophet Muhammad
know all of this stuff that I'm reading
right here I I I'm a very educated
person I know that he couldn't have
known this
no has not changed one letter
to be quite honest I didn't want to
believe that especially being in jail
there's a lot of uh Shady individuals
and you really don't want to believe
everything that you hear
so I ended up talking to an Imam that uh
goes to the jail and does Juma on
Fridays I spoke to him
and he said look these are the books
that will educate you on what you need
to know
I read those books and I still doubted
because I said how is it that the author
of this book they tell me it's a law
it's got to be Allah but I need to make
sure so whenever I got out I was a
Muslim right and I I believed in the
Quran because I said there's no way that
this came from man
but I wanted to go search when this book
was written I really wanted to know when
I got out the sources all pointed to the
same thing this book has not changed and
this is how we can prove it hasn't
changed this book is a book that is
memorized
it is a book that you can grab the last
Quran on the face of this Earth you can
throw it overboard and it will still be
known you know why because it's been
memorized by millions of people since
the beginning of the book
it's like the blockchain right it's
amazing I I look
I I just don't understand
anyone that reads that book
they just they're they're mine they're
gonna their mind's blown like it's it's
amazing I think the only formula to
often repeat this is they got to have um
the right intention sincere they can't
be wanting them because you know a lot
of times
you know you're in the situation and
someone's explaining this to you about G
this is one example of Jesus who is he
praying to he's praying to himself he's
God and then you're just like okay it
doesn't make sense but then you see some
people go in circles they'll end up you
know just pulling things out of a hat
and just wanting to argue and whatnot
but you were sincere obviously you're
here and you're yeah no and I mean and I
I went through a a huge struggle where
you know I I made it right I made it at
17 years old I signed the contract of my
life right and I thought that you know I
was in Paradise but then
God came in show me show me the devil
yeah let's talk about that I opened up
in the beginning people may be still
thinking what do you mean you got to
know that God's real the devil is real
oh yeah what do you mean what do you
mean by that so I mean you know
when you when you make it into something
like baseball right something that
worked your butt off or you know I I
worked hard from 13 years old all the
way to 17 years old so I want to say
four years I dedicated
all my my time all my emotions all my
focus into baseball right and I saw
these guys on TV and I said man these
guys are living the life
these guys are playing they're making
lots of money they're driving nice cars
so I ended up making it to that level
but when I got there I saw what's in the
background what you don't see on TV I
saw the emotional
um effects that all of these things have
a lot of guys depressed a lot of guys
using drugs still I made it to the top
still depression is real for them
depression the drugs
alcohol look I didn't see
people doing cocaine until like sex
addiction that's like sex addiction I
mean
I I know I had an addiction to women it
got the alcohol uh started to get to me
uh popping pills
um just to bring the emotions down wow
so many things are expected from you at
that level the pressure is high right
especially me I had a lot of pressure on
me because I already had a cousin who
was super famous in baseball and they
wanted me to live up to his expectations
oh yeah I got to get to that level
so I ended up getting knee surgery
before I was even drafted and that
already had a little handicap on me so I
felt the pressure even more because I
had to compete with these other guys
so these guys you know I thought they
were perfect seeing them on TV you know
I thought that they were living that
life they were happy they were living in
paradise and
again I had not seen anyone take drugs
until I got there I had not seen the
alcohol consumption that I saw I had
never been invited to a strip club I was
only 17 18 years old and I was allowed
to go into the strip club because I was
a professional baseball player you know
I was able to do things that a normal 17
year old wouldn't have been able to do
18 year old wouldn't have been able to
do and it got to me it got to me because
I I I was under the impression that
these guys were clean right that these
guys were following Jesus to the letter
and that's the reason that they got
there and that's the way that they
stayed there but because these peers
also are Christian these are yeah a lot
of these are other religions anybody
else other people think we're just
focusing on are there any other religion
or these are mainly or people are always
Jews Jews and Christians are the only
ones involved in baseball you know it's
uh it's a it's called the
judeo-christian sport no way I didn't
know that yeah so there there was no
Muslims there and I honestly don't think
there's been any Muslims is that
children that's how it's been
established as a judeo-christian
Christians baseball yeah baseball I did
not know that yeah so
I didn't know anything about Islam at
this point yeah I the Quran was
something you know the only thing that I
knew about Islam was what I saw on TV
and Eddie I got to tell you I was born
on 9 11. you were born I was born on 9
11 and that's my birthday right so
imagine me going to school one day you
know uh fresh to death in my uh my new
outfit very happy and then I get put on
to uh the World Trade Center being blown
up and then everyone's saying that
Muslims did this right I think that's
something that ingrained in my mind
because for every birthday
I couldn't I wasn't I was taught not to
forget about this right and I was taught
that you know all Muslims were basically
like this yeah right so imagine you know
me being a Christian uh born on 9 11 uh
seeing what happened in the World Trade
Center and I still children I want
people to think about that I don't know
something came to my mind people are
still trying to figure out what happened
to Bill D7 but anyways that's a great
story
look at it you know without getting into
all of that you know I had my I had my
doubts and and one thing that I always
thought in the back of my mind was why
do they vilify Muslims so bad right and
I can tell you even until today Eddie uh
you look at a at a character like uh or
a person like Andrew Tate right the top
G
why do they vilify him so much
especially after he became a Muslim
right
so it's when when the when the Whole
World Trade Center thing happened and I
saw the way they acted and they talked
about Muslims I was always intrigued to
why they were like that why are they
doing this
because I feel like every single time
that people are trying very hard to
vilify an individual there's got to be
some type of Truth in there right so
it intrigued me to find out about Islam
after that right
um and before I I met these uh Muslim
individuals who debated me and and gave
me the Quran and all of that
I was already a little bit intrigued
because of the whole 9 11 theme right
because I wanted to know exactly who who
are these Muslims right and
I ended up having a couple of Muslim
friends uh pass and hack em uh you know
guys from my neighborhood and they were
really good guys these guys had
businesses these guys
um lived a very good life they didn't
drink they didn't smoke you know they
were what I thought Chris uh Christians
were supposed to be right but I I just
never never really asked them anything
about it you know uh because I just I I
understood at this moment I thought that
it was a religion for Arabs only and
they were Arabic big misconceptions yeah
yeah and I was really uh impressed uh I
kind of slid in you put together a
little talk
they're on Twitter yes and I really like
the topic that you had and I didn't know
that so from the interview that I did
with him is that how you ended up
getting turned out to Andrew yeah and
then I get turned out to you from Andrew
Tate so it's very interesting how things
just went around Eddie and now you're
actually putting together some protests
yes yes to try to help to get him free
yes there's a pro tip that you're
actually the head of and you're having
to organize yeah true yes so Eddie
before we get into Andrew I gotta tell
everyone that the way I learned about
Islam after coming out of jail was via
the dean show right so I've been
watching you since I was 22 23 years old
and I learned so much
so I gotta thank you a lot for my Muslim
education but you know to get to Andrew
you know watching your show via you know
all these years
I was told about Andrew first by my son
and my nephew and my nephew was making
this uh British accent asked me what
color my Bugatti was I said why are you
asking me and why are you talking like
that and he said Uncle you should look
into a guy named Andrew Tate because you
remind me a lot of of him like how
masculine you guys are and stuff I said
I don't know how masculine I am but I'll
look into them and Eddie I got to tell
you
um right then in there
Andrew comes on to a podcast and starts
talking about Islam and then I see him
on your podcast so when I see him on
your podcast I said man if Eddie's got
him on there I gotta listen to what this
guy's got to say so I I listened to why
he thought that Islam was the future
um in terms of religion and why it's the
last religion and his uh point of view
and and then I I saw him take a shahada
with Tam Khan
so I started to think about myself
and everything that I've already told
you here of my previous lifestyle as a
Christian and um you know especially you
know I say that I was a Christian but I
was still living like like uh someone
who didn't believe because uh even in
Christianity you were you know we're not
taught to go out to the nightclubs and
hook up with women you know although
it's allowed no one's telling you not to
do it
um I felt like I wasn't a Believer so I
see Andrew coming on the scene
he's intrigued with Islam he's learning
about Islam and then he becomes a Muslim
right
and then everything happens to him right
after that in terms of uh the charges
and all of these things I start to think
about myself and I said well I'm a
Muslim Reverb and I wasn't perfect
before I became a Muslim and I went to
jail uh on false charges
so it's like Allah was connecting
everything right he's on the dean show
he then gets charged with some bogus
charges now here I am right and I'm on
Twitter and I'm learning a lot about his
case via the Muslim Community was uh
there's uh a couple of people who were
speaking a lot about him uh Suleiman
Ahmed a summer pattern a couple of
Muslims who were basically defending him
uh from all of these attacks that were
happening on Twitter I was able to learn
a lot about his case remember I told you
I have a knack for for for law now yeah
because of my situation
so when I dissected everything it just
didn't add up for me and I said you know
what
Allah put it in into me to to help this
brother so I ended up uh creating take
protest.com
and say protest.com is basically you
created that now I createdprotest.com
take protest.com so I created take
protest.com in order to do two things to
inform people of the injustices in in
the take brother's case and to put a
worldwide protest together so it was
it only started uh as something that was
going to be held in the states and
London because uh they are from the
states and they have citizenship in in
the UK yes
but then we got so many requests from so
many people around the world so many
people wanted to help him because I
guess he's helped so many people and the
Muslim Community you know they were in
the front line because he became a
Muslim and he was very sincere about it
he started to talk about Islam in a very
positive uh way and we all recognize
that Islam is something that's been
vilified for many years so
I felt as a brother who has the
knowledge to put a website together to
understand law to um
to relate to his prior lifestyle because
I understand a lot of Muslims are not
okay with his prior lifestyle I'm not
okay with his prior lifestyle
but I lived that prior lifestyle and I'm
not I'm not a hypocrite and I know that
once you take shahada Allah releases you
from all of those sins
so Allah forgives you from all of those
sins you start with a clean slate
and that's what was afforded to Andrew
when he became a Muslim
so I did not want to judge him for his
prior lifestyle
I saw a lot of attacks from both the
Muslim and non-muslim Community about
his prior lifestyle but I was able to
look past that for two reasons I lived
that prior lifestyle and I became a
Muslim and I know what that second thing
means become a Muslim
it's a pact between you and Allah
Allah then releases you of all your sins
it doesn't matter what anyone thinks
in this world
once Allah releases you of those sins
you come with that clean slate now it's
up to you to become a better person
well he was taken uh away from us via
the justice system in Romania soon after
that this is a coincidence I don't know
right after he accepted Islam right
after he accepted Islam he goes from
Dubai Islam lands in Romania and that
case was actually started prior to him
coming back it was already since April
last year oh yeah so is it over about a
year so the case started he was first
rated April 11 2022.
they go there they they look through all
his stuff all his computers all his
cameras they find out that these women
are lying they immediately release them
now these guys are going back and forth
from Dubai to Romania nothing ever comes
of it no issues as soon as he accepts
his slum next thing you know they're at
his door he's he's uh you know basically
guilty before even you know getting
getting his chance in court
still has not even been charged till
today right
it's crazy I mean just seeing that
always reminds me of why as Muslims we
we tend to be reserved right because
here in America we've been vilified for
for many years uh likewise in other
countries I understand that he's in an
Eastern Orthodox uh Christian country
um from his own mouth he gave a lot of
money to the church before I don't know
if that has anything to do with it but
the timing of it Eddie is very
suspicious
very suspicious yeah so now you go ahead
and I can see exactly what you're
talking about because uh you see that
it's a lifestyle that many of us lived
we were in that lifestyle yeah and if
God Almighty Allah can take a man who
has the Bible in his back pocket
tattooed with Jesus if he can take
myself
and also bring me to where I'm at today
interviewing people like you he can go
ahead and take a man like I should take
Tristan Tate and have them serving his
Dean and delivering this message like
he's been doing holding the Quran
walking into the prisons now it's step
by step it takes time I know he gave up
alcohol
he's given up a lot of these things
there from the past
webcam and the only girls and all that
stuff yeah and the gambling all this
stuff he's making strides forward these
things take time
took time with you it wasn't just like
and then all of a sudden you're an angel
right and still to this day where should
we make mistakes but yeah we turn to the
most loving the most kind the merciful
the Creator that happens in Earth God
Almighty Allah or we're striving to uh
go ahead and make things right with our
creator and live upright morally upright
lives yeah obedience to God Almighty so
you see that I see that in hamdullah
he's making strides forward yes and uh
what's the latest now what is uh so I
know that he went to court I believe
they went to court today they had today
he had court now yeah they had a court a
couple of days ago but the hearing was
today to see if uh they were going to
drop the the investigation yeah they
didn't do it they didn't do it do you
know on what grounds why they're I don't
I don't know on what grounds you know
what people need to understand as well
is that when these women uh filed this
report uh initially on April 11 2022
when they were released the brothers
were released then they went and filed a
report against the women
and nothing has come from that they
don't even talk about it they filed
something because the women were lying
so they wanted the women to get charged
for putting them in that situation and
nothing has come from that either so
what we can see is a clear bias against
them not only from the Romanian
government but the mainstream media as
well you don't see any positive
headlines when it comes to Andrew Tate
so I feel that the people who were on
Twitter uh speaking and defending his
name uh they did a lot of good work
because where where do we get our
information from we usually get it from
the mainstream media you know but uh
thank goodness Elon Musk took over
Twitter and now we're able to have uh
more uh free speech and to come back to
the protests
the initial date for the protest was
going to be April 11 11 2023
essentially what I was doing was giving
them an entire year to either release
them or charge them they didn't do it
they didn't charge them and they ended
up releasing them because once they saw
the pressure from everywhere countries
from around the world I'm talking about
India
the countries from Europe
South America Canada the United States
we had people from everywhere you were
organizing all of that yes so what I did
was I put a team together a team of five
to six individuals uh were spread out
all over the globe and we uh put a
telegram Channel together and we are
able to communicate with each other and
they opened up channels for specific
countries and then what we would do is
get leaders from those countries to put
in for uh permits to protest and these
were going to be peaceful programs
the scope of the law peaceful tell me so
then this guy they got released before
the protest they did they did well you
don't know now this could have been
definitely had an effect now you're like
hey we gotta get these uh guys out
before these protests happen I feel I
feel that
Allah put it in my heart after he became
a Muslim
he got into this situation he must have
been praying to Allah and Allah must
have connected me because I don't think
I would have done this for someone who I
felt number one did it was guilty and
two someone who's uh not committed to
the proper lifestyle of Islam
when I see that someone takes that
shahada that testimony of faith that
they want to become a Muslim that they
believe that the prophet Muhammad was
the final messenger and they want to
become a better person via that
lifestyle
I'll do it for any of my brothers
so Andrew he just so happened to had
already been spreading a good message
before he went in and a lot of people uh
were captivated by that message and now
him becoming a Muslim I feel that his
message is even going to become more
powerful and I felt that it was my duty
as a Muslim brother to do everything
that I could
you know I feel like God put me in
everything that he put me through right
I feel like he put me through all of
those things to prepare me for that
moment
because it is a big one of the biggest
things that I've ever done in my life
and I've accomplished a lot of things in
my life you know I've put together a
non-for-profit softball leagues 300 plus
people
um you know I've I've ran multiple
businesses including uh teaching
baseball to kids I've been a baseball
instructor for years
but this worldwide protest was
definitely the biggest thing that I've
ever done in my life so is this all so
you have it set for April 23rd for the
protested for April 11th April 11th they
got out when did they get out March 29th
March 29th so what happened to Olivia
okay so the uh protests they got put on
hold for now or yeah we just got
canceled so we postponed the process uh
essentially what we want is for these
brothers to be exonerated yeah either
they charge them or exonerate them
because if there's no evidence there you
know I always thought that there was
torture keeping these guys in detention
with no charges for that amount of time
during it was coming on three months
that's clearly human rights violations I
mean and that's what it was all about
that's what the protest was all about
was about human rights because we
wouldn't want this to happen to anybody
this is a human rights issue it doesn't
matter if it's Andrew Tay or if it's Joe
Shimon if an individual is being held
without charges for a very lengthy time
right and this individual has health
problems this individual is not able to
see or speak to certain people in his
family you know now this becomes a
human's rights issue and these are
things that were put forward by the
people that I was following on Twitter
who were attorneys and they were putting
out all the points so what I did was I
grabbed all those points created take
protest.com put all those points on
tayprotest.com and then gave people the
platform in order to start a peaceful
protest in their community
reward you for this effort and you don't
know this might have been the reason
that because this obviously it's full
circle it's full circle we've got all
these countries now coming together for
this protest and just coincidentally now
Allah made it that they have freed him
and let him out he's not officially
clear yet he's out in the jail but he's
still under house arrest yes he still
can't be mobile
so we don't want to end it until until
we make sure that a resolution comes out
where look if they have evidence if they
have evidence of a crime charge him and
and give him whatever it is that you
need to give him in terms of time or a
fine or whatever but don't torture these
guys
don't don't put these guys back in jail
unjustly for a lengthy amount of time in
horrible prison conditions right give
them their due process
fulfill their human rights so that's why
we stop the protests but if they were to
throw them in there again without any uh
evidence of of or charges I should say
right because if there's charges there's
most likely evidence
they throw them back in there with no
charges where we're coming out we're
going to come out and peacefully protest
because that's just what we have to do
as humans we have to protect each other
especially as Muslims we have to protect
each other we wouldn't want this to
happen to anybody I know that the pieces
add up to Tristan Tate his brother
also except in Islam I don't know I know
we sent me and Sheikh man we did I don't
know if you got a chance to see that we
sent the message to uh Tristan Tate
inviting him to Islam it's a very nice
uh yes I've seen it and uh but is it
official did he do you know if he's
actually took his shahada I don't as
much as you're guessing no no I I don't
I don't know you know he's not there the
fastest yeah yeah yeah avoiding poor I
actually put I actually put out a tweet
uh you know I said if uh
it's a conspiracy right now it's a
conspiracy theory of mine that he may
have took it in and I want it to be true
I want it to be true because Tristan is
a great guy there's a great guy I don't
think look Tristan seems very sincere
genuine you know that's what I like
about these brothers I was really
impressed he's got the uh Bosnian from
where I'm from the uh my family trainer
and he was like you know I'm old school
I'm not gonna go and do something that's
going to upset my trainer he's got you
know yeah really respectful those I'm
kind of I'm old school myself you guys a
little bit younger than me so I see
these things and I'm betting on these
guys because I know what Islam can do I
know if someone has cancer if someone
has a deal you know the medicine and now
you're betting that if they take this
medicine if they take Islam they're
going to be at a whole nother level
their character is going to be a whole
nother love they're going to invite into
good forbidding evil they're going to be
people who now are going to make a
really great impact of good gas in the
world yes yes and and they've already
started I know that via the Ramadan they
did a lot of Charity and like you said
Tristan has all the qualities to become
a great Muslim a very uh good
influential Muslim and uh Tristan if you
see this um we're welcoming you to Islam
you know uh we need you brother uh your
brother's already there and I'm sure
he's giving you the invitation we're all
waiting for you
um we all appreciate everything that you
do absolutely and you now him seeing
this inshallah Tristan sees this also
now he sees someone again Gotta Sink in
tattoo Jesus Bible in the back yeah you
know and you really you are heavily
invested I was I got a lot here going on
I mean this is you really are thinking
deeply you're praying on it and you come
this far that you're actually I got a
Muslim beat up over Jesus Christ you got
a Muslim beat up or beat up beat up over
Jesus and then I almost got killed
the things turned around yeah and then I
ended up giving that Muslim brother a
hug uh telling him that I appreciate him
because I I took my shahada with him uh
he's actually no longer with us uh he
was from Somalia and I I think he was at
a war or something and uh and uh but
I'll never forget him his face uh may
Allah have mercy on him
um but but yeah brother uh it's
something that I now hold dear to my
heart is Islam and
I often tell people look if you do
something very simple and you're sincere
and you ask for guidance from the
creator of the heavens there alone no
intermediary nobody or I just had
somebody I did a program with and he
came from a Serbian background and these
things like just really stand out he was
confused and he's like God if you want
me to pray to Jesus who do I pray to
just unconfuse me just guide me to the
way that you want me without coming in
and saying look Jesus guide me uh
Muhammad guy you know the one who
created Me Guide Me yes very
straightforward goes with the fitra the
innate nature that we're created with to
worship God Almighty alone it's in the
Lord's Prayer or father God has a
Hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done submitting your will to
the one God that just makes sense so if
you're asking that God Almighty Allah
the Creator you didn't even say Allah
the one who created Me Guide Me I'm
confused I'm in a world of confusion the
devil's all around me these forces of
evil I want to do good guide me there's
no way of Tristan inshallah if he
watches this and he prays for God if he
or if he didn't know already we don't
know if he didn't that they would lead
them to go ahead and do something that
his brother did
Allah
there's nothing worthy worship except
Allah the creator of Muhammad is the
message that's what I mean and then he
would uh he would accept all those
messages that came before him Jesus
Moses Abraham the line of preceding
Messengers but give them their rights as
Messengers not as a part of God or like
Jesus and I saw you going back and forth
and you know you're really into sharing
now the dawah yes yes yes let's touch
upon this you know the importance also
before we conclude of not keeping that
truth just for yourself having that
confidence also to go ahead in a loving
caring way to show because I don't want
our Christian friends out there you know
I believe any person who surely wants to
be christ-like do what Jesus did Jesus
did Islam he was a Muslim they're going
to transition smoothly they're going to
come over just like you did so this is
out of the love that we're going and
sharing this message with the Christians
and others out there who are seeking to
know the purpose of life why we've been
created where they're going with their
die they want to connect to make it
right with their creator they're going
to come to the same way of life of Islam
that you did yes so you know uh for
those Christians that are out there
listening you know I have a lot of
Christian followers on Twitter I go by
the conservative Muslim and I'm speaking
a lot about Islam and I'm doing
comparisons with Christianity and I
don't want them to believe that I'm
trying to knock Christianity
but I want to say that I just don't
agree with the church and where we're at
today in Christianity because we see
what's going on in the churches in terms
of you know who's getting married and
the type of individuals who are leading
um you know just recently also say that
he he affirmed this whole thing if you
want to you know he's catering to a lot
of these yeah yeah he saw catering to
the new ideology which I know a lot of
Christians are upset about so I want
them to know that you guys have a way
out Islam is not going to take anything
away from your beliefs aside from uh
pure monotheism which is believing that
one God
as Christians we believe that the only
way to get to God is via Jesus but as a
Muslim we understand that to get to God
you just have to go straight to his door
God will open that door for you and this
is what Jesus taught Jesus taught that
there is only one God
and that only God is the the Savior the
one that can save you he directed
everyone to God so what happened after
Jesus I believe was the church took over
and played with this message and now is
confusing everyone to believe that you
have to go to Jesus to get to God making
him some type of Middleman
I understand that people want to believe
in Jesus we believe in Jesus in the
essence that we believe that he is a
prophet a messenger who came to speak to
the children of Israel and that he is
the Messiah who will come back to defeat
the Antichrist Christians believe this
as well so I want them to know that
there is a bridge there between
Christianity and Islam but what I would
like them to really look at is the
evidences that we see today
which religion is accepting this satanic
ideology that we see is it Christianity
or is it Islam we have to be honest with
ourselves right so
I had to be honest with myself
I got that guy beat up when I was in
jail didn't want to accept the message
that he was saying my head was big you
know I had this huge ego I wanted to
look good you know I I felt empowered by
I don't know what
but at the end of the day I had to
humble myself down and I had to look and
see the truth
that's what everyone needs to do they
just need to look around them and see
the truth
which religion is it that's protecting
children that's protecting families
that's pro-life that's pro-business
right and you'll find that in Islam and
they'll see that Islam is not too much
different than Christianity we have we
have a lot of the same beliefs right
but it's the pure monotheism that we're
bringing to the table that you can go
straight to God and when you have that
connection with God everything just
becomes a lot better and the blueprint's
there that you didn't have at that one
point early in life oh yeah everything
from when you wake up in the morning
the structure is there throughout the
day to when you go to bed everything is
there and how oh my goodness it
functions so you can go ahead and avoid
the Hellfire and get the gender to
Paradise by submitting to your career
not to your desires or human being or
anything in creation but the one who
created creation God almighty
people can look you up at the
conservative Muslim there you have your
Twitter yeah and they can follow up and
uh connect with you yes they can and
check out tapeprotest.com you know uh we
don't want to take our attention away
from take protest.com or the Tay
brothers because they need our help in
this moment they're not free and clear
right and they're getting these uh what
they call Matrix attacks right from here
and there or whatever and we're trying
to keep uh everything alive because we
don't know what what could happen so you
know for those Muslims out there who are
doubting Andrew Tay I want them to know
that
they should endow the prophet Muhammad
said that as a Muslim we shouldn't try
to find a fault in other Muslims number
one and number two we shouldn't have
false suspicions against Muslims you
know so we have to pray for the brother
that he becomes a better Muslim I mean
absolutely right so and uh as as for
Tristan
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
[Music]
we're here with uh
yes yeah all right guys so we signed
everything here
what's up gotta get the keys now
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened and basically
it's far further south from the other
other big massages and everyone I know a
lot of people that I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another uh Uncle of mine lives about
five to ten minutes from here this area
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
yeah the center this Center is much
needed for this area and the idea of
this Center is needed for the whole
stick because we don't have anything
like that in the whole state that that
was sensor where it's gonna basically
nurture and basically educate and it's
gonna basically spread the slam